The world of ninja is harsh In
reality, there are various rules and things that happen, and those who break them are called trash,
but hey,
those who don't value their friends are even trasher.This
year's students have cleared that point.
I guess I passed
when everyone challenged me So, didn't you say it was
amazing?
The
correct answer is to join forces with your comrades,
because even in real life missions, there are many difficulties.
It's
okay, sir, it's okay to keep talking and open up a
relationship, so the customers will think that
you're good, but you did a good job this time.
Well, this year's graduates are right.I don't think there's any prospects for the time being
.
I'm just chasing after the students